an argument over a selfie may have led
to the death of a 22 year old American
in Greece Macari Henderson was killed
after a fight broke out at a bar near
early Friday witnesses told police he
and his friends wanted to take a photo
with the waitress which angered one of
the bouncers well it happened on the
Greek island of Zakynthos it's a popular
destination for tourists tonita copal is
here with a look at the suspects under
arrest 20 good morning good morning
police say at least 10 people followed
Henderson out of the bar including the
bouncer and another employee they're
accused of beating Henderson and leaving
him unconscious in the street eight
people have now been arrested and are
facing charges of voluntary manslaughter
the eight suspects including the bouncer
and bar employee covered their heads as
they made their way into court oh do
they miss another building in one of
their attorneys argued there was no
intent to kill Bukhari Henderson who
Greek police say died from severe head
injuries after the beating the news is
still sinking in at the McRae household
in Austin Texas the family friends say
Henderson spent a lot of time there
growing up I think everybody feels the
same way Henderson graduated last month
from the University of Arizona with a
degree in business finance and
entrepreneurship in a statement
relatives said our family is devastated
they said Henderson was a big thinker
and enjoyed coming up with new business
ventures his latest a photo shoot for a
new clothing line brought him to the
Greek island of Zakynthos
the nightlife in an area of the island
known as lagana
attracts a rowdy a crowd according to
author and travel writer
Lenny gage we got a lot of charter
flights from England and other parts of
Europe that can make for a very cheap
vacation for primarily young people
looking to party there have been reports
of trouble there before in 2011 an
argument with taxi drivers led to the
stabbing death of a British teen and
last year a young woman from Britain
said a spiked vodka drink left her blind
yet this case makes no sense to those
who knew Bukhari Henderson like neighbor
Norton he didn't have any of those
characteristics that you would think
about to play in terms of warring brawls
Corey's nature so I'm just we're told by
Henderson's family their main focus now
is getting his body back home the US
State Department says it's helping the
family and is in touch with Greek
authorities meanwhile a GoFundMe page
has raised more than thirty thousand
dollars to cover transportation and
funeral costs
Gail all right very sad story thank you
very much Tony vacation shouldn't end
like that